how's gum roses beep ah today we're
playing the very organized staff
Christmas edition whatever that means
others oh yes ah yes say my Santa Claus
I think I'm Santa Claus so what would
Santa Claus do in a situation like this
I would steal all their [ __ ] this is my
TV santa needs gifts to boom alright
let's see here we need the Christmas
stocking I need that alright give me
give me some of that
I need a bicycle I know where the
bicycle is there it is that's my bicycle
what else do we need Christmas pudding
oh yeah that's my Christmas pudding no
no no no what else the hell they put a
TV there Christmas stocking huh must be
here somewhere
Oh money damn it ah sap album yes it's
not a Christmas stocking yes oh my god
I'm gonna be rich goddamn it I need the
code but I need the key I think I saw
the key downstairs how does the
television still work oh god they're
coming oh god they're coming why - for
Sarah I six uh uh open up and open up
and up and up and up and hurry hurry
twenty money money money money money
money money so much money oh my god
Santa's gonna have a nice vacation Oh
God I've got a better hide I better hide
in the closet thank God [ __ ] oh my god
every time Oh Tom Cruise Tom Cruise stop
stop Tom Cruise Tom Cruise he's beating
the [ __ ] out of me ah run run run run
run run run I'm sorry who would beat up
Santa whoo-hoo oh no escape ah
I just came scares the [ __ ] out of me oh
my god hi hey I'm an everyday thief
thief no I'm Sam I'm Sam towers reverse
shifting I was gift reversing have you
never heard of that
you take [ __ ] from people it's great
alright let's give this another go I got
a new list a TV yes my TV thank you DVD
player thanks idiot
these are now my gifts up my Christmas
tree yep
who steals a Christmas tree who alright
the barbecue yes I know what that is and
then a laptop and gonna dig dude dig it
chill Nikita
alright barbecue come with me oh yeah
that's a laptop yes there's a car yes
hahaha there's a painting I wrong
painting dammit where's the painting
which painting darris ugly-ass painting
yes I mean it's it's probably worth a
fortune noon there's a digital camera oh
my god I could get all the items yes
take it our camera Digimon digital
monster okay where's the stamp album
where is dawei is La Stampa
albumen ah yes that's English what stamp
album is that you yes gold bar all we
need is the gold bar all we need is two
gold bar all we need is to Goa bar yes
yes yes yes gold bar oh oh oh
I borrowed all the things oh my gosh I
never happened before this is amazing
oh my god but as there's still stuff to
take there's probably money and stuff
okay that coming Tom Cruise is coming
home god damn better put everything back
the way it was okay don't panic
I want the Christmas tree Christmas tree
here come with me Tom Cruise is not
having a Christmas son of a [ __ ] Tom
Cruise is coming Tom Cruise is coming
Tom Cruise is coming I repeat yes and we
got the Christmas tree later [ __ ] oh oh
damn there's a lot of money there yes
damn hey Tom
hey Tom it's me I got all your [ __ ] Tom
Tom doesn't know what to do I got all
your [ __ ] what you gonna do about it
[ __ ] Wow in your face Tom Cruise in
your face oh my god
that was amazing professional thief oh
my god that was awesome
all right breasts gonna have to end it
there I hope you have an amazing
Christmas with a lot of great gifts and
if you didn't you can just blame me or
that or you could just
ungifted Ohno I'll leave it up to you
but that's all for me for now leave like
if you are watching bus and as always
stay awesome bros
well that's too psyched to side to side
health pack destroy it watch okay I
destroyed it oh god it's a Nazis
dammit any big box get it they're crazy
take this Nazi scam